elle est considérée comme catastrophique
dans les yvelines dans le secteur de
l'hôtellerie la perte de chiffre
d'affaires pour l'année 2020 et 2 54% en
moyenne les locations de vacances
sont-elles relativement épargné avec une
baisse de 17% ce qui est très important
de se dire c'est qu'on s'y retrouver
avec une majorité de clients français ce
qui est plutôt pas mal mais la clientèle
internationale
les seuls qui ont perduré un petit peu
sont les belges qui ont continué de
venir une perte de visiteurs qui se
ressent aussi dans les sites
touristiques et culturels parmi les dix
lieux les plus visités en 2020 le
château de versailles france miniature
et la bergerie nationale sont les plus
touchés on a fait des actions qui
étaient très liées justement à la pompe
dénis et avec par exemple les quartiers
d'été puisque les quartiers d'été bien
sûr s'était tourné vers la jeunesse et
vers les enfants des quartiers un petit
peu en difficulté mais ça a permis aussi
à une trentaine de professionnels du
tourisme et bien d'accueillir à des
jeunes aidés par le département alors
que les centres de loisirs étaient
fermés les professionnels sont partagés
pour un retour espéré à la normale entre
4 mois et un an
le département va de son côté continuer
à proposer le pass malin un nouveau site
internet sera aussi proposée à la fin de
l'année 2021 pour répondre aux nouvelles
attentes des touristes